today we're going to check out these
Rayband glasses and it looks really
different because it glows let's see
what's inside hey it's gone what's
happening of course I was wearing them
in the previous scene this is how the
ray band meta glasses look like and the
audio is captured straight from these
glasses itself the metal classes allow
you to capture really cool point of view
shots like this sh with my dog or even a
business class trip on Singapore
Airlines to check out how the entire
seat and experience looks like
all this is done with a touch of the
button on the metal glasses one button
press takes a photo second takes a video
and the camera turns on and you can see
a nice LED glow to let people know you
are recording the case is used as a
charging do and recording 41 minute
Clips stre the battery down to about 50%
I think it's a really cool to and if
you're serious about social media do
check them out